almost nobody knows this in I think 2009
I had a short bout with sobriety that
started at a rehab facility in Malibu
California
and they're making so fuss one day after
I've been there for a couple of weeks
and they put me in a car and took me to
uh to the Bel Air hotel which made me
you know pretty curious and they took me
to a table and it was Robin Williams and
Bob Gawain and know Bob's been sober for
25 years not oh I don't really remember
how long probably been sober and I don't
know he can continue to struggle with it
and as I did and but hey I know we
didn't really talk much about the
amazingly dull subject of sobriety but
he just made me laugh so hard so hard
and Bob did too and enough it really let
me enjoy life for a little while and
really remember what it's like they're
fun and they you know he helped me write
a bit I mean it was we spent I don't
know two and a half hours and and I you
know and I'll never forget it me and no
reason to do it he didn't know me and he
said he was familiar with my work and
you know I hope you liked it anyway to
you Robin the wish we still had